tourism rebounds in las vegas nate
mccarran airport trying to fill
positions
they sure are those positions left
vacant by the pandemic and our hector
mejia
is live at mccarran airport talking
about the travel demand and
keeping up with those jobs there too hey
hector hey there guys good morning the
department of aviation is holding a
career expo later on today at 10 a.m
with
dozens of positions that are either open
right now or in the works to become open
in the next few weeks
but soon tomorrow terminal 3 will reopen
we're standing along sunset across the
street we have a view of the entire
runway
and way out there we have the 14 gates
at terminal 3 that have been closed for
quite some time
that's all changing tomorrow when the
airport reopens
half of those gates mccarran airport
says travel demand is getting close to
pre-pandemic levels of 2019
three and a half getting close to four
million
monthly passengers that's the latest
number from the airport
they also tell us westjet came back
earlier this month next is air canada in
august
and then low cost carrier flare in the
fall
the airport says they need workers so
today from 10 a.m to 3 p.m they're
hosting the free career expo inside
terminal 3.
jobs and administration custodial
customer service
parking and here's what chris jones with
the airport says led to some of these
vacancies when kovit kicked in
we lost a lot of people through early
retirement we've lost some people
through attrition
we really weren't able because of
budgetary issues to begin resuming
hiring people until the first of july
when our new fiscal year kicked in
so we've also learned the last time the
airport planned a career event this
large was back in 2019
i'm sorry 2012 to open terminal 3.
it's not a fair where you get offered a
job on the spot it's more to really
connect with recruiters and learn about
the positions with the department of
aviation and you can actually check out
what they have available
by going to mccarran.com and again that
expo is from 10 a.m
to 3 p.m today inside terminal 3 and if
you're worried about parking they will
validate for that for you today
reporting live hector mejia 8 news dan